thank you
whoops
are we on are we on oh yes
okay
uh
welcome
we haven't had a division two meeting
and um how long mickey six months
yeah this is uh this is quite exciting
um
i was hoping that
representative rawlings would be here
this morning
um
maybe he's afraid of us or something i
don't know
we're such
wonderful people i can't believe that
anyhow he
he did he did provide an amendment
that uh representative lynn
has um
sent out
and um
this replaces
the um
well what we heard
last week whenever that was
so this is a replacement uh amendment to
hb 1300.
so if you um
i i hope i i think i had sent this to
everyone
ahead of time
but
it's
anyhow
the
yes
uh
i have a question
yeah i can hear you okay i don't know if
i was supposed to keep my no you're not
you need to pull it closer tom
there you go
now push the red button
there you go then pick your finger up
you should be okay okay
so um if i remember correctly that
um
the last time we met on this on this
bill
we wanted the
if there was any funds left over we
wanted them to go back into the general
fund
no what i see on this what i see on this
amendment is it just goes back to des
moines yeah that was not this bill
that was um well that's still my
question about the amendment it's just
it seems like it just goes in circles
here
it's just if they don't if they don't
use all the money it goes back to des it
doesn't go back to general funds
it should go to the general funds
shouldn't it
yeah
anyway that was my question okay okay
all right mickey mickey you said someone
was here from d.e.s
uh yeah we have uh sarah kern from the
department here possibly to answer
questions i think they just saw this
amendment this morning earlier today for
the first time oh okay
but uh she is here to answer questions
all right sarah why don't you come up
i'm sorry you're so far away this is
uh this is not the
not the norm for division two uh or
your previous division division one
but uh let me just say we're um
we're happy to uh to have you and uh
it'll be our goal to get to know the
people in des and uh
and we
we thank you for being with us this
morning thank you okay
okay did you want to say anything
or do you
well i know that director wimsat
testified at the hearing i'm uh director
wimsatt's assistant director sarah euhas
kern but you can just call me sarah kern
because that's much easier i'm sorry can
i get you what's the last name again
uh legally you host y-u-h-a-s
space kern
k-i-r-n
as in nancy
but i'm happy with just kern thank you
thank you
i would as you know the department is
not taking a position on this bill so
i'm just hoping i can answer any
questions that you may have
you had a question i i did um and i i i
know that i
what i'm going to be asking you in some
regard a repeat
of
uh or at least close to what i had asked
at the other hearing but i'm still not
quite sure i understand could you just
take us through
typically
what happens when a landfill
closes down in other words i know i
understand that there's this requirement
that you that the you know the owner
provide these financial assurances that
kind of thing but can you can you just
kind of run us through that generation
in other words suppose that a landfill
is owned by
some county or local level of government
and then it's going to close down sure
at the time that the permittee applied
to be able to build the landfill they
submitted a closure plan that was
approved by des so when they close down
they follow the steps that they have
outlined in their closure plan
and those can include things like
putting the final cap on the landfill
and then they follow steps to maintain
the closed landfill it includes
mowing the top of the landfill if the
landfill generates leachate like the ash
landfill then that leachate needs to be
collected and disposed of and the
collection system needs maintenance and
checking
um
landfills generate hazardous gases
landfill gas so there are systems at the
landfills that control the migration of
those gases so those systems need to be
monitored and maintained we need to make
sure that gas isn't migrating
anywhere that it could pose a risk
there typically our groundwater
monitoring wells to check whether
the breakdown of materials in the
landfill are contaminating the
groundwater and could pose a risk to
drinking water so there's a schedule by
which the permatea needs to have those
wells sampled
and the
financial assurance that they
demonstrate
is to demonstrate that
if they were to become insolvent
there's at least 30 years of money
available that the state could access to
pay for the continued maintenance and
monitoring of the landfill
okay
follow up so can i just
so again let's assume that the landfill
we're talking about is owned by
some level of government a county or
municipality or whatever so
when you say they have to provide
some financial assurance
i mean what is that in other words do
they have to like post a bond or
thank you for that clarifying question
because if the landfill is owned by a
government entity
they have the option of
doing the local government financial
test to demonstrate that
their entity has the money moving
forward in the future and then that
satisfies their financial assurance so a
public entity would not have to get
put in place the instruments that a
private entity would those instruments
for a private entity could be
a surety bond an insurance policy
a trust fund
an irrevocable letter of credit
i think the rules reference or other
mechanisms i asked our staff what other
mechanisms do we see and they told me on
rare occasion a certificate of deposit
okay can i ask one other follow-up
question so so let me turn it suppose
that
i mean i take it that with regard to a
to a municip to a municipality or some
level of government
the assurance basically would be
the the
the level of government's taxing
authority we can if if we don't
if if something goes wrong here we have
to pay we're going to tax the
inhabitants to pay for the i mean is
that basically correct
while that makes sense to me i have
never been the one to review a local
government financial tests so i would
really want to check with our finance
person to be sure but that is logical
all right can i ask one another oh yes
that's fine just one of the so let me
switch gears from it suppose that if
this is a privately owned landfill and
suppose that
you know it's in financial difficulties
in other words suppose the owners say
yeah i understand that the you know the
plan is we have to we have to have a
bond we don't have the money we can't
you know we're going to go bankrupt or
we don't just we don't have the money
what does des do then if they you know
suppose they investigated they find out
yeah they really don't have the money
what do you do then
well
the permittee was to demonstrate up
front before they got their permit that
they had the money
this econ situation is a very unique
situation
so econ is the only one that i'm aware
of where they
had the sufficient money in the
beginning and they no longer do
the the
rules and statutes of course um
give us authorities to enforce the rules
and statutes
but uh of course we'd rather find a
better workable solution
thank you very much i'm sorry yeah no no
that's that's fine
um
are there yes please go ahead
okay thank you
can you clarify because when you were
speaking here you used the phrase 30
years that they have to have money for
30 years
and if i can remember correctly from the
hearing before these people
believed they had 30 years they planned
out for 30 years and then somewhere
along the way the phrase a rolling yes
so when you said 30 years
did you mean 30 years because that seems
to be what they understood and that's
what they did
but now we hear that there's a rolling
30 years which is basically 30 years in
perpetuity so can you clarify that for
me sure that's a great question
the rules
that are currently in effect require a
rolling 30 years and and the reason for
that is because a landfill does not
suddenly have no risks after 30 years
the risks continue although it's
possible that the cost of
managing them decreases over time
the rules were clarified in 2014 because
there was um confusion on
many parts
about whether that was a fixed 30 years
or a rolling 30 years
our position is that it has always meant
a role in 30 years
but it's clear that there was a lack of
clarity
on both sides at the time that
the this permittee
took ownership of the landfill
if if i understand correctly
the they followed the rules that were in
effect
in what was it 2011
when when they asked for the permit
or they identified what the what they
needed to do to close the landfill
and then um
and so they
put aside that money
you know
and then later on
when you
clarified the rules
you changed the or the des
not uh
des says
your
landfill closure plan
is no longer
good enough you need an additional
x amount of money to take care of
30 more years
is that am i reading this correctly or
i know you said your initial rules you
thought that that's what it was well
this is the difficult
one of the difficult parts of this
situation our position is that
even in 2011 even 2009 that the rules
always meant a rolling 30 years but they
didn't state it clearly enough
if you as as econ points out if you look
back at the
information in their files and ours it
appears that there was a lack of clarity
on the des side as well as on the econ
side
please oh let's oh i'm sorry yeah
representative heath go ahead so my
understanding is that this entity
is a private entity it has it does not
have the capacity or taxing authority
so
right now the current situation is that
they use some of these funds
to maintain
this
landfill
and now they're in a situation where
they're all volunteers
and it's they're stuck
so
does this amendment mean that 500 000
would be
put
in a fund at des
for this purpose
now
one more question
unrelated to the amendment is wonder if
this landfill
fails
and des has to take it over
so one way or another this is kind of a
conundrum
um
and
why do we have to fix it
is my question i guess
thank you
i don't have an answer
[Laughter]
so your first question um about
where would the money go if it was
appropriated
econ does have a financial assurance
mechanism it just doesn't have enough
money in it so my understanding of the
bill is that the money would come to des
and we would immediately cut a check to
econ's trust fund which is held at
citizens bank right now they can always
move that around if they want to with
our approval
um
so that's where the money would go
on your second question what what
happens if
econ
dissolves
and the landfill fails or or even what
happens for the maintenance if econ
dissolves
at that point we would what we could say
call financial assurance and start using
the trust fund whatever money is in it
to pay for whatever needed to be done
for the period of time that it lasted
and
eventually it would run out
and the des does not have funds
dedicated to maintaining and monitoring
landfills
but it would need to be maintained and
monitored
so
des would look to the governor and the
legislature for for where that money
would need to come from
thank you
okay
representative
thank you madam chair thank you for uh
testifying
i have a series of questions if you
don't mind
first question is it the department's
position
that
the rule was not
changed but clarified in 2014 just yes
or no that is our position yes thank you
okay next question
can i continue oh yes ma'am yeah please
instead of asking this is a work session
so i'm just learning about this and my
first introduction was an article i
pulled from september of last year on
this so i'm
using that as kind of a base uh
currently how much money is in
the
trust fund or whatever they're calling
it right now do you know i have notes on
what was last reported to us somewhere
around 800 000 is that correct
i believe that is correct
yes uh
approximately 883 000. oh 883
and
why
the reason we are here is that the
number that
is supposed to be maintained on a
rolling 30-year basis is
is 9.92 correct
the 992 number is not one that i entered
into my notes
um but this is an important question
uh the amount that needs to be
maintained on the 30-year rolling basis
is
is calculated
in the closure
post-closure cost estimate that the
permittee is required to
update every three years and that
closure cost estimate is to be for a 30
year period
we do not we have not received
a post-closure cost estimate for for
this landfill
since 2016 and it was for 15 years not
for 30. so we really can't comment on
what the total amount needed is at this
point in time
uh we've been in in close communication
with econ
and i am aware from just yesterday's
communication that they've had an
engineer working on in a 30-year
post-closure estimate
and um it should be ready right around
now and they're interested in talking
with des about it and we'll definitely
make ourselves available but um
at this point we don't have the number
that's necessary you don't have a
current one what was the number
associated with the last estimate the
last estimate which was for only a
15-year period was
so that excuse me that was from
2016 to
2031. is that correct
that's correct
and final question
so it is the department's position that
once you get this new estimate that's
the total amount of funds that should be
in this rolling 30-year
number as of
now is that correct it's a little more
nuanced than that okay
once we get that updated estimate we
need to review it and
maybe the changes to it will just be
tweaking the numbers because the cost of
mowing has changed over the past five
years
but perhaps and what happens sometimes
perhaps they will propose to change some
of the activities they're doing for
post-closure maintenance
in that case if it's a change to the
post-closure activities
that's going to need a more thorough
review by our engineers and we'll need
to go
carefully through what they propose to
do and through what the calculations are
and
um
eventually we would
ask for changes or approve it based on
what we see it's too soon to know we
don't know what it'll contain
i lied that wasn't my final question you
just gave me a new one
so when you get and you redo your
estimates and the department
makes their calculations or whatever
the current amount in the
we just talked about somewhere around
883 or whatever the number is
conceivably
the department's number could come in
beneath that number
it's really hard to know because i i
don't know let me rephrase it it could
come in below or above that number
that's what i would say yes thank you
okay
represent petry
thank you man of chair
yeah i got a couple of these beauties
next to me
the cardinal landfill which i'm sure you
know nothing about but they have a trust
to take care of it and
you know that's
like a blind trust
and they they take care of theirs
are they required to have the same
thing right next door to that one
is the town landfill
and they we we have we maintain a
capital reserve fund and when
funds are needed we take it out of that
so
i'm i'm surprised that
this uh this entity
has it by itself because it seems so the
town of newport should have the response
the responsibility because they probably
put the refuge there is that correct
this landfill
actually accepted ash that came from
municipal solid waste from a number of
different communities in new hampshire
and vermont
and at first
the
the permittee for the landfill was the
the coalition of those communities
but um back in the early 2000s
uh
econ took the landfill over
now if if econ fails all right
it sounds like you have insurance within
des of the bond or i assume it's a bond
now wouldn't the city of newport
they would inherit the land so to speak
and wouldn't they be responsible
to take care of it
we're getting into some legal questions
and i'm a geologist not an attorney
so i don't think i can comment on that
thank you
representative lynn you've been very
patient i'm sorry you know what can i
i'm just trying to follow this through
if
as i think i asked the last
the last time we had
if i understand correctly there's no
there's no precedent for this and for
what what is being asked for here in the
sense that no other
no other
landfill
has said
we misinterpreted
what the regulation meant as the 30
years rolling versus 30 years fixed is
that correct
i don't think i can say for sure what
all the other landfills have said but uh
we're not aware of any other landfill
that finds themselves in this situation
yes
so the thing i guess i'm having i'm
trying to sort of envision what
what kind of precedent this would set
in other words suppose that
suppose that the situation was you have
a landfill that you know got
they they gave you the appropriate
assurances for 30 years rolling and it
was you know x number of dollars
um
and then
because of inflation or whatever the
call you know the costs of
doing the maintenance
went way up
would
would that mean that it would be okay
for that landfill to come to the
legislature and say we want
you know we want an appropriation to
bail us out i would think that might
have if that was a basis there might
that might happen with some regularity
well des is not taking a position on
this bill and and
whether it's something we should do
but what i can offer is that there are
more than 400 closed landfills in the
state most of them are owned by
local entities
we estimate there are about 50 that are
owned by private entities and from what
we can tell econ may be the only
non-profit that owns a closed landfill
in the state
yes representative
thank you madam chair
and thank you sarah
um
so my question is how did they how did
this
um organization
put the uh fund this trust
originally
and uh tom
let's save that question for uh mr
pinken uh well my question is if they if
they did if they depleted what they had
did they go to their own stakeholders
first
or did they just come to the state i
think that's a question that um
the uh
nonprofit
needs to answer and will and and and by
the way in the last time we met on this
i never heard this these numbers that
are being thrown around like the 883 000
balance that's still in there
we never heard that
that's true
yes
represent murray thank you um
it seems like you know the 883 000 seems
like rather a lot of money
and i guess i have two questions related
to that if i
if i miss
remembering let me know it seems to me i
have the understanding that
because this kerfuffle arose
that des
was not releasing money for the um
the landfill to continue to do its work
and
first of all can you clarify that the
second thing is
that's a lot of money to hold when it
seems like that landfill is not asking
for a lot of money in order to do its
yearly job
and that
because regardless of
where the problem was des is a
professional group econ i guess is their
name of more of the volunteers and it
seems it's incumbent upon des to help
out here and be a little creative and
flexible in finding a solution
so that econ can do what it is that they
apparently are trying very hard to do
your your first question
touches on
a concept that
can be confusing
the financial assurance mechanism the
trust fund
is not
intended to be a debit account that pays
for the maintenance it's intended to sit
undisturbed
to be there in the event that the
permittee becomes insolvent
however
if a
mechanism like a trust fund has more
money than is necessary to cover the
estimate for post-closure maintenance
and monitoring
then the permittee can request for
disbursements
from the trust fund
that's what had been happening leading
up to 2016
that
des was authorizing disbursements from
the trust fund to help out with the
maintenance and monitoring
also a very unique situation
then it was in 2016 when the situation
of
there not being enough money in the
trust fund arose
and and at that point in time we weren't
able to authorize any additional
disbursements
um
as far as your your second
question
the
des is the entity that permits these
landfills
we we don't have funds to maintain and
monitor landfills
we operate under the statutes and rules
that are in existence and we we can do
what's allowed in the statutes and rules
and we've been working really hard in
close communication with econ to try to
find options under the statutes and
rules but we are limited
by those regulations
represent petri
thank you madam chair
uh thank you for taking my question
is there any place in the in the
law to waiver some of these fees
or this uh
trust
some of you know the what we're trying
to do here
to waive the requirement for financial
issues right well it's it seems so
there's some ambiguity as to what was
interpreted and uh
you know that's that's going to be a
battle in itself
des the rules that des operates under
usually include waiver provisions
and the provisions usually say that
there needs to be an equivalent
option presented
so if we could find that
that that may be something that could be
looked into
thank you
are there any further questions for des
okay sarah don't go too far no problem
very nice to meet you all yes nice
meeting you i probably should have
introduced everyone to you but uh
that's okay
okay
would you mind coming up mr finger
it's
pink good to get picked
kim
okay
all right
um since this is a work session we
basically are
asked questions answer questions and
because at the
original um
bill hearing
we did um
you know hear
from you
now
maybe before we do that um
represent rollins right
coming up and i know that you provide
this amendment
and uh some of the folks did have some
questions on the uh
the amendment
that maybe we could do that first have
you looked at the amendment yet oh yeah
yes
okay
i was asked to put the amendment in by
econ
okay
and i would like to have
mr pickens talk about that because he's
the expert on it but this was a request
from econ to put in that amendment okay
okay
that's fine
so
please mr pickett
first foremost thank you again for uh
having us here today
certainly myself and on behalf of econ
and newport citizens we appreciate your
consideration
and i can assure you in hearing a few of
the questions that came forth um
when when uh sarah was presenting
you know we would not be here unless we
had to so we are all volunteers most of
us are either business folks or owned
businesses in town and we have looked at
every possibility that we can in order
to meet the financial assurance so this
is certainly not the number one
option we had this is the oh my goodness
if we don't at least look at this option
we may have to fold up shop and
that landfill may go into the hands of
the state of which the wonderful
taxpayers of newport would have to our
newport as well as the state would have
to pay for anyway so again what we are
trying to do is we are trying to
continue on with our steward or being
steward of that landfill to take that
off from the onus of the state to ensure
that it continually is maintained
in the fashion that has been maintained
so
you know this is definitely a fishbowl
so we have gone to some
one said something about stakeholders we
have talked with every stakeholder we
can
we had a meeting in newport that
included all of our delegates it
included the state it included the
attorney general's office
it included the
joe kenny councillor kenny it included
the town it included a number of folks
so again this is not something that we
have not looked at all possible
opportunities for us to basically
look for a solution for this and it was
truly at that meeting when we vetted all
of our options that we met with you know
senator ward representative
rollins as well as um
councilman kenny and they said look they
spun the situation and based upon the
midstream change in what happened with a
state organization i think we need to go
to the legislature so again this was not
me saying oh my god we've got to hit a
pot of money this is our representatives
that basically said this is exactly what
we're here for so that is why this bill
is here the first bill was basically a
placeholder because we did not have the
time and energy that we now have had to
work with experts so we are working
closely with des and when
sarah indicates that's the case they
have been but their hands are tied they
have
regulations and and laws in place that
just makes it very difficult for them to
do anything to help us in them out
we are also working with nobus
engineering so novus is probably one of
the
premier engineers in the state and novus
has been on this job since we took it on
back in
2006.
and then we are also working with
council because i am not familiar how to
sort of work
this
scenario so we are working with um a
gentleman who is an environmental
attorney expert and actually used to sit
as a head of
the attorney general's team for the des
so again we are working with everyone
and anyone and the partners that we
think we need to work with to figure
this out and that's why we're here
everything pointed to you gotta at least
give this a shot because it fits the
criteria that we believe
might look for consideration
so the amendment was put forth after
having
further discussions with all partners
because we had some time in order to put
that revision together
and that is basically the culmination of
the way that all of those parties um
believe
that this could best work so
and and again whenever you want me to
stop and answer questions i'm happy to
but there's just a signifi there's a lot
of information that that i wish i was
here earlier and unfortunately i was
literally sitting outside and thought
you were on the first agenda item
um so i only caught the last but the
actual amount in the trust is not 883.
so as of the december 1st 2021 statement
from citizens bank where the trust is it
is seven hundred and fifty six thousand
dollars and
uh six yeah seven hundred fifty six
thousand six hundred forty nine dollars
however that's overstated because we
have bills outstanding for five years
from the town that has been supporting
our efforts without being able to get
the money to pay them
they basically withheld five years of
invoices because we were not able to get
that money released by the des so the
town understanding the importance of the
landfill basically
gave us an invoice of 172
699 so that money is already spent that
is the work that the town did over the
last five years to meet all of the
criteria necessary from des
so we have not been able to pay the town
because we cannot provide the financial
assurance to allow the des to have us
take money out of that account to pay
the town so at this point in town the
town said you know we feel we have done
what we can we have done this for five
years
but we also have to collect this for the
taxpayers of newport we are no longer
going to be able to do this gratis until
you figure out what is going on and
again that is what's pushing a lot of
this resolution is because we right now
do not have the monies to pay for the
maintenance of a landfill
so if you were to take out the 173 000
from the monies that's in the trust that
basically leaves us with 584 000
so that is the monies that are in the
trust
and then we have been working with
nobis
very diligently um
on what the annual cost of that landfill
will be so i didn't want to come here
without numbers and have you opine over
something without knowing exactly what
it is
that we would need in order to support
and meet that financial assurance
so if we were to take a look at all of
the annual costs associated as well as
take a piece apart of the capital costs
that we would have to do over the next
30 years we basically would need 820 000
and and before i start des has not seen
these numbers so just to put that forth
we just finalized these yesterday after
a very long meeting to make sure we
brought it to you folks um so 820 000
of that eight hundred and twenty
thousand there is a ten percent
contingency so that is built in for
future years should interest rates go
awry or sure or or should inflation or
interest assumptions
sort of not be exactly what we're
thinking that will sort of absorb some
of the question so we need 820 000 we
now have 534 so there is no way at this
point in time that we are going to get
the okay
from des to allow us to use any of that
money to continue managing that landfill
so what we are looking for because of
that midstream change or as they call it
a clarification
um regardless it has put us in this
position
you know we are unable
to provide support
in order to manage and monitor that for
the folks in newport the folks of the
state
the monies are just not there
so if we were successful and if you
folks were to consider this to a
non-profit and i'm not sure someone had
said something about precedent that is a
great question and the first one that i
would ask and the first one i thought
someone would ask before i stepped in
here
you know if there is ever any other
non-profit that took on for the benefit
of a town the ownership of a landfill
without ever earning one dollar on that
landfill
and if indeed rules were changed such
that they had enough prior to but when
the rule changed they did not any longer
have it i would say that's a good
precedent and if there was another
organization that was doing that that
got into this situation i would hope you
would also consider that so this is not
a precedent for the 50 landfills this is
a precedent for a very very unique
situation that i have not had the chance
to speak to anyone professional or not
that has ever seen this happen before
never
um
so if we were to put that 500 000 where
that to come to us
um that 500 000 would basically go
towards
the
requirement of financial assurance
um and then also as you know
we pretty much not only need the
financial assurance but we need the
money to actually pay for
the
expenses
so this is again a one-up we are the
only organization that is having to use
820 000 that we just have to amass as a
non-profit and sit aside and never use
it you know i do not know any
organization nonprofit or not that has
that requirement unless it's restricted
but it's usually restricted for a
general purpose at some point a capital
needs project or something
so the onus on us as a one up is to come
up with 820 000 that we just kindly
leave in there into perpetuity
and we have to also come up with the
expense so remember this is only taking
care of the financial assurance so with
that 500 000 we still have some left
over from that financial assurance
package that the des is only going to be
looking for the amount we need for
financial assurance and then we will be
able to cover the expenses with the
amount that we have left over
but even in that particular case you
know we will have 464 000 as an
organization
to
go
through other means to try to find that
400 000
and again we just need to get the
financial assurance piece done first
in order to meet the legislative
requirements to at least be able to pay
anything
um so that's a situation we're in i
apologize i know you said but i just
wanted to make sure that's okay
uh representative
can i ask you you said
as you were making your presentation
that this was the only non-profit that
you were aware of that did some that
undertook something like this for the
benefit of the town and so i guess my
question is if you did this for the
benefit of the town
and you're now
you know short on money
why shouldn't it be the town
who was the beneficiary that that is
responsible for
coming up with the money as opposed to
the state
so the town manager actually sits on
econ
and he used to be the president of the
organization and because all of this
basically came to a head he stepped down
so
i am relatively new to the presidency
since june when all of this basically
took place
because of a significant conflict of
interest exactly based upon some of
those things that you are indicating so
when i ask him that exact same question
he says look mark we're only one of 27
towns that put trash in that landfill
it's wonderful for us to be able to
support you but we are not going to
cover the expense for 26 other towns
trash who put originally a million one
in there to cover 30 years the 27
districts did exactly what they were
asked at that time by the des and by
everyone that negotiated there was 1.1
million dollars put in there to cover it
and then the 27 towns basically said
we're going to do that and we're also
going to give you an extra 200 000
just in case you had to cover any
remedial cost for a significant spill or
anything that's unexpected so you're
getting 1.3 million dollars in order to
do that
so
there is an inexpenses change we've done
everything you've asked us
based upon the law the regulation the
agreement with the exception of a change
in clarification in 2014 that said nope
it's not 30 anymore now you have to have
a rolling 30.
so they
trust me it's an ask but again you have
to go back to the town and have the town
take on a liability or the town do
something on behalf of 27 other towns
when they sign that indemnification
agreement like every other town in that
um group
you ought to follow up then um so if i'm
understanding and and please understand
sir i'm in in any way faulting you you
know
in some personal way or the board or
anything like that but i guess as i'm
as i'm trying to understand this
if
let's suppose that the the
towns that were involved in this
had not been under
what des says was a was a
you know a misunderstanding as to what
their requirements were and that and and
that may have been reasonable or unreal
i'm not
making any judgment on that but let's
say
that the towns had correctly understood
that they needed to have a 30-year
rolling
assurance as opposed to 30 years fixed
it sounds to me like what that would
have meant is
that the towns all would have had to
would have had to would have known at
the beginning and would have had to put
up more money
so in a sense
they've
they've put up
they've gotten the benefit if you will
of putting up less money in the
beginning because they were under this
misapprehension
and so again i come back to my question
if that's true if they got the benefits
so to speak of putting up less money so
presumably all those 27 towns had that
excess money to spend on something else
and now you know
now it's come time to pay the piper so
to speak
why shouldn't it be those towns
that have to put up the extra money as
opposed to the state
and that is a great point and one that i
would love nothing more to go to the
towns and just have them open up their
coffers and say mark regardless of
anything that we signed way back when we
feel for your position and we are just
going to cover your expenses until
perpetuity at whatever expenses they
will be
um and i don't mean to be facetious but
if indeed they knew it was a rolling 30
every single time that we would have to
present this to the des in a three-year
period for the next 30 years it wouldn't
have been written as a one-time amount
for 30 years and there certainly
wouldn't be an indemnification agreement
that said
this is subject to change in rules
subject to change in regulation and
don't come to us if expenses go up so
that wouldn't have been the negotiating
piece for us
it would have been every three years if
these expenses go up we are going to do
financial assurance for the next 30 and
if we don't have enough we are going to
divvy it up amongst all you towns that
is exactly the way it would have been
written if they would have known or we
would have known it was a rolling 30 and
not a fixed 30. so if we were to go back
that's exactly how it should have been
done but you only have the information
and again
all this was signed off by the
commissioner at that point in time i
mean the commissioner is the one that
was releasing the funds from the trust
and in his letters he basically said you
know
i as a commissioner allow you to take
this out because there's enough to cover
the remaining 15 years of this agreement
i mean i i it's not unclear it is no way
um i i know they say it's a
clarification it was not unclear not
unclear at all i can show you all of
those letters where they say you're good
to go for the remaining and all of a
sudden you know the next one comes in
and says just kidding you know now we
need 30. so
and that occurred in 2016 is that
correct the actual law change i think
was 20. that wasn't a question when did
they stop allowing you to we were unable
to provide financial assurance in 16.
okay so that was correct
so the last five years again that's the
five years that the town has been
covering our expenses
um
awaiting hopefully
a resolution
and again we we've tried and had
discussions with the des
and i do believe their hands are tied
because their regulation says you need a
rolling 30-year financial assurance and
trust me i think they are willing and i
don't mean to speak on behalf i think
they would be willing to do anything
reasonable within their control i mean
they do not want to take this back
i mean they really really do not want to
take this landfill back and that's right
from the commissioner's mouth
representative bucco you have a question
thank you
thank you madam chair
um
no i there was just one other thing that
i wanted to add is that the state
operates on a two-year budget and this
is the off year
and generally when we get special
we get special bills like this we when
we usually don't fund them in this in
the second year until we come around and
put another budget together
so a couple things on that
um
the premise of us ever having to use the
state's money
is nearly
statistically nil right because the
monies that are in that account
can never be used and the des controls
it and the des will not allow us and i
can assure you that over the last five
years they're pretty good at that will
not allow us to take money out if we
don't have enough to preserve that
financial assurance which is the state's
money so the way that we look at it it
is a placeholder
in order for us to meet financial
assurance but monies that we're never
going to use
so the only way that we ever use that
money is if we can't afford the annual
expenses and the state takes it back but
the way the bill is written is
if
there is any well first of all the good
news if this closes and sarah indicated
a number of these closed so if this
closes within the next 15 years i mean
this is probably one of the strongest
and best managed maintained line
landfills in the state
so if it does reach a closure 500 000
goes right back to the state
so the monies are being expended um
and i know that doesn't answer your
question but i guess
the timing isn't as critical if we knew
it was coming
and that could be one of the
negotiations with des right so they they
don't need it today
and i don't mean to speak on behalf of
the des and sarah can certainly come up
and indicate if if i'm indicating
something wrong
but i'm not sure that we need it today
we just need to show that we're going to
have it
so even if it was to come in at another
period of time you know that is
something that we would go back to the
des and say you know pretty much
guarantee
as far as guarantees can go so but we
would prefer it because it it's cleaner
but if that is an impossibility
you know we could probably work around
timing
represent heath
thank you madam chair
um this is
very confusing
um
how do you raise the funds for the
yearly maintenance right now you already
owe newport for five years
so number one how are you going to get
that money
how are you going to continue to pay for
the maintenance
now you're asking for this 500 000
another question is what's your
succession plan i mean you have this
board
are you going to be there forever
i just this is a problem with lots of
unanswered questions that just
bothers me greatly great question and
the first one i can answer a lot easier
than the second because i can only speak
for myself being on there and i don't
foresee myself i mean i've been on there
for 20 years and if i was to give you
sort of the membership if anyone was
going to jump they would have jumped
over the last six months right because
right now we spend 100 of our time
having nothing to do with economic
development in town all having to do
with run in ash landfill so if anyone
was going to jump i assure you
even me we would have jumped and we
would have handed the keys over to des
because that's the easy answer right
that's the real easy answer as a
volunteer is why am i going to spend 40
hours a week doing something
that takes me away from my day job so i
think folks will definitely be around
but i cannot guarantee the organization
has been in existence since the early
90s too thick and thin
and many of us are still there so i can
all i can give you
is as much comfort level as that gives
you
the second one with the numbers so the
way that the numbers pan out
156 000 in that
account
if we were to get
another half a million
we would have appropriate financial
assurance to take monies in order to pay
the town 172. so after we take
the monies that we have now
minus the 172
plus the 500
that would at the end of the day
leave us with about 464
000 in our coffers while still having
financial assurance at 8 20
to cover
expenses and the way that the expenses
work is the annual expenses only run
around i mean the annual testing
expenses only run around 17 or 18 000 a
year
where the other expenses come in is more
capital replacement so we have to
replace a leak j tank at 50 grand or we
have to replace those are not going to
happen every year and those aren't even
going to happen within probably the next
10 years
so
that 464 000
basically over 30 years
provides enough monies for us to cover
those expenses and we would reserve that
ear market keep it and then the other
thing we've been able to do and again
we're looking at every possibility so
also on that property is a garage so we
have negotiated with the town of newport
to rent the garage for some of their
equipment for 5 000 a year and then the
police department
has a
shooting range in which they used to
train their
staff and that as well would give a five
thousand dollar annual so we have
recurring revenue of ten thousand on top
of that twenty six thousand which over
time we are just hopeful we would always
have enough to cover um those definitely
annual expenses
but the capital expenses as well at
least that gets us i hope 15 20 years
and that's a long time for us to figure
out additional income in order to keep
this going right now we don't have time
i mean we're right now under the gun of
the des with 90 days to come up with
financial assurance not 15 years
so all right thank you sir
representative murray you had a question
oh no okay
okay uh representative petry
thank you madam chair uh thank you for
taking my question
uh where does that 26 000 where does
that come from
your revenue
so it would come from the excess monies
that we would have when we take the
amount that we currently have in the
financial assurance plus the half a
million were we to be
where we to get your consideration
we only need to keep 820 in that account
so if you basically take the total
amount we have now less than 120 that is
the amount of monies that we would have
in our own coffers to cover the expense
uh
follow up
so
you're spending at least 17 plus
incidentals
you you don't have in other words you're
not keeping to build that
or maintain your uh your expenses what
where's that com where's that excess
come from
again i have a spreadsheet but i don't
want to bore you with the numbers
because we also haven't um shared these
with the with with the des so we have
and i apologize i'm not explaining
explaining this well so we have two
different components right we have the
financial assurance which is 820 000.
right now
we have minus the 172 000 due to the
town in newport we have 584 thousand
so that's the monies we have now
the other part a piece of piece of this
and maybe this is where the numbers
don't add up for you folks
understandably is we have that
additional 200 000 that we have never
spent so we have 200 000 that was also
provided to us
at the time
that we took over the landfill so we
have that two hundred thousand so right
now we have seventy we have seven
hundred and eighty four thousand dollars
right now
to basically cover
820 for the financial assurance and then
presumably 820 for 30 years
so
if we were to get the half a million
dollars on top of the 784
again that is what would allow us the
monies
above and beyond the financial assurance
we needed to cover those expenses for a
significant period of time which will be
at least half of it or close to half of
it on an annual basis will come from
recurring revenue from the town's rental
of 10 000.
follow
so
so you're getting a revenue of 10 10 000
possibly so the 26 is what
it's not every year
that you have a revenue of 26.
no not a revenue but we would
deplete from the reserve that we have
based upon taking all those monies
together and having some excess over and
above the financial assurance
that we can't use we will still have
a bucket of monies that we will
deplete over time in order to cover
those expenses
until we figure out how to not only get
10 000 but we figure out a stream of
income or an income source to get us the
full amount right now is that 200 000 is
that liquid
yes
so okay so you do have yes you do have
backup so we we put that basically in a
reserve account the day that we um did
this deal and it's still sitting in that
account because that was part of that
indemnification that we needed that 200
um but again we are hopeful and we have
not spoken with the des so i'm somewhat
hesitant but there is no restrictions
that we can't use that 200 000 towards
the financial assurance piece so if it's
sitting there not being used anyway it
would be nice to have it sitting there
and not being used anyway but help to go
towards the financial assurance thank
you thank you
representative
thank you madam chair and
thank you mr pitkin
uh a few questions the first one
and i i think you weren't i think you
said you weren't the president at the
time so you may not know the answer to
this this is more of a philosophical one
and then i have some numerical ones for
you but
why was the decision initially made
by this non-profit to take over a
landfill the numbers we heard were it's
the only one out of 400 in the state
what was the thought process behind
that so
at that point in time
the landfill was closed and there was 27
towns that were trying to manage this
one particular piece
and from what i'm told it was just a
logistical and administrative nightmare
and one of the solutions was always
to open up the remaining two cells so
it's a four-cell ash landfill only two
cells were used by opening up those two
cells i was also told
that we would get incinerated ash not
just from folks in new hampshire but we
would be pulling in incinerated ash from
all over new england so literally
newport would have become the trash town
so we would have had trash trucks
coming in daily and again just
everything else that goes along with
that type of operation
so at that point in time the president
of econ also happened to be the town
manager so again you can see where
conflicts
but it really wasn't a conflict because
we worked so close together but it was
at that point in time when they all
negotiated and said okay
how can we do this to preserve that from
never being open again
to have it go under a conservation
easement for the benefit
and it's right on the claremont line so
i would say claremont as well
but for the benefit of newport while
making sure that econ collects enough
money so it is not harmed financially
over that 30-year period
so minds i guess much greater than mine
got together and there were attorneys
that and that were on
both sides so they come up with this
plan that was supported by the selectmen
in order to preserve newport as not
being the dump town the land is now in
conservation based upon that process and
then they worked with the des because we
are the again we are the first
non-profit not only to do it we are the
first one that ever received a modified
permit for a closure as being someone
that is not affiliated with
the refuge business to manage so again
we had to go through significant
hoops i believe at that point in time
because this was something new for the
des they said oh my god but again it was
proven to the des that this
process and the support
mechanism of that monies would make it
plausible so if you were to ask me would
i do that today absolutely not i mean
i'm a banker i understand liability
issues i understand hazardous materials
right we stay away from them
but i can't speak for you know the board
at that time or at least those that put
it together
but i can tell you that at the time it
appeared to be a very good solution to a
very difficult problem with 27 towns
thank you
you mentioned the 90-day period that the
des has given you when does that expire
um we're getting calls daily and again
right thankfully maybe over the last
couple days so i think it might have
already expired sarah do you know
so
i i think it's probably expired expired
already
um
you talked about
possibilities if you couldn't come up
with the numbers or whatever
in your opinion what
what would happen
to the
first of all i guess what would happen
if your numbers uh you can't meet your
numbers what do you
presume what will happen and when and
the second part of that is the money
that's currently
held whatever we've gone over a bunch of
numbers whatever numbers remain what
would happen to that
current amount of money
so this is what i'm told and again i
don't mean to speak on their behalf but
again i've been part and parcel of
conversations
so the monies and financial assurance
are basically there to cover the expense
should
one of these individuals that operate
these become insolvent and then it goes
back to the state and then the state
presumably has that security
in order to continue to manage it in the
manner and fashion that it was
so
any monies that we have
in that
trust fund would go back to the state
so the other alternative now is the
state could definitely take that back
with
584 000 after paying the town
but again there's resources involved i
mean
i understand they find it's less
cheaper
and much more efficient for us to
operate it than if they operated it i
believe totally understand and
thank you for the question uh the answer
um
i think i had one more you mentioned
uh i guess this isn't a conservation
easement now yes
it's probably silly i guess i
was a conservation group i probably
wouldn't want to touch it with a 10 foot
pole but has any conservation groups
been approached on this
so the only piece that's in conservation
is the actual landfill itself so we have
approximately another eight acres that
is not
necessary to be in that conservation
area or the area surrounding
the landfill that is not required again
to be monitored and managed and that is
held by the town so the only one
presumably that was yeah the town is
part of that holds the conservation so
there's eight acres it's not in it and
then
what's the acreage of the
total
just curious not important sadly enough
i don't know i know the eight acres
because again that was one of the
options try to rent it try to lease it
try to sell it or even have the des take
a mortgage on it i mean we've tried
everything we can
but again if it's not liquid it's very
difficult for them to um
if it's not liquid or if it's not able
to be raised
through
through tax
tax assessment means i would say maybe
it's an additional
six
i i don't know
thank you
we get a chance to speak with sarah
again
of course thank you
may i ask so if the
and this is maybe in some sense it's a
rhetorical question but i but i think
your input would be important if
as you said before if if you have if if
you have evidence that in in you know in
the past before there was this
clarification des had basically said you
know you can
you can spend the money that you've
proposed to spend and whether because
you have enough
you have enough to you know to guarantee
this for 15 years
why wouldn't it be an appropriate
resolution of this matter
for that
for
des basically because of of
its sort of reinterpretation why isn't
an appropriate resolution for that for
your group to say to des look
we relied on you
and now we don't have we don't have a
sufficient amount of money
that's your problem you're going to have
to
you you're going to have to take the
risk
of having a
less of a bond if you will
to guarantee the assurance of this
than you might prefer
but
that's kind of the way it is and we're
not you know
i mean why wouldn't why wouldn't that as
opposed to the state appropriating 500
be an appropriate resolution
so i was i was basically told
i believe and again sarah can absolutely
positively um give her opinion on this
so a couple things happened if indeed
the requirement was still only 15 years
and we could use the monies in order to
cover the expenses for 15 years that
might be a viable solution not one that
they would probably accept but for us a
viable solution but now what happens is
we not only have to have
the monies for 15 years but we have to
be able to pay for them extraneous to
that amount so even if we did that
they'd say or potentially could say fine
leave the 15 years in there but now you
still have to pay for it for the next
30. so we still don't have the ongoing
operation expenses because they still
won't allow us to touch that even if
they say that amounts enough however i
believe
that in order and again i'm speaking out
of turn but you wanted my opinion it's
just that
in order for them
to circumvent
the actual regulation it would require
some sort of carve out from a body
that
is supported by you folks so like a
legislative carve out that said we know
you require 30. we know that's the law
but we are going to allow a carve out
for our econ and again i am speaking
well out of turn
um
and i think sarah said
appropriately that they have a
regulation and again they say we are
sorry we're so sorry but you know we
have looked at everything we can do and
when we got the letter of administrative
order um it just basically said our
hands are tied you have to come up with
a 30 year
so that's a great question i i think
we would be willing to work with
something like that
but i don't think it solves the problem
of going forward and actually being able
to pay for those expenses
that would solve for the 15-year
financial assurance but we still would
have to pay for the expenses annually
if that makes sense
so can i just am i understanding then
from the very beginning
of this
you were paying
for sort of ongoing expenses out of the
original monies that were put up is that
correct and that with with with
the at least tacit approval of des at
least up until 2016. yes that's correct
so
the monies that paid were what was
approved by the commissioner to take out
of that financial assurance trust fund
to pay the ongoing expenses
and then we were told we can't do that
anymore so not only do we need more on
the financial insurance side but now we
have to cover the expenses so again it
is a double whammy it wasn't just a
single whammy
it was a double whammy where we have to
come up now with you know over a million
dollars in total whereas before we
didn't need anything
if that makes sense thank you
representative murray
thank you now i have two questions
i think ms kearns made a comment that a
new analysis is being done
um if you can speak to that is that
possibly that's going to be an
optimistic analysis from your point of
view and secondly is there a way of
having a discussion that perhaps this is
working the way it's supposed to as i
understand trust and endowments
it's still frustrating to me in some
situations where so much money is tied
up that can't be used
and that this is maybe a situation where
this fund is being used appropriately um
i think to representative lin's point
that yes you don't have this and
regardless of misunderstanding or rules
change whatever now it's an appropriate
um use of this money um can you sort of
speak to that as a potential argument
thank you sure again great questions i
appreciate it so
we indeed are working on an analysis and
that's sort of what we
finished up yesterday
so as i said everyone has been
supportive and stakeholders we've gone
to nobis nova nobis has given us and i
probably should be announcing this but a
significant discount
on what they're doing for us because
they understand our plight they don't
have to they just truly truly want to do
what they can so they do our annual
testing our monitoring and our reporting
to the state
and that makes us feel good because the
state always tells us again that the
process and the monitoring and the
managing is one of the best so they have
no issue with what we do or how we do it
certainly not nobis so they have cut
down their expenses there were a lot of
things where they were subcontracting
out a number of things that we pay them
to do so what they did was they put us
in contact with the actual contractors
so now that we are able to contract with
those folks that literally go and take
the testing and so on and so forth so we
saved a significant amount on that end
as well i've spoken to the uh the folks
that uh transport the leachate they're
helping us out and even the guy that
does the mowing so trust me i've gone to
them and i said we've got to get this
thing down to as thin a margin as
possible because that's what determines
that financial assurance amount is you
take the annual amount you multiply it
times 30. so that has been basically cut
down um to its bare bones the one piece
that is very difficult to cut down is
capital expenditures
so that's the part or piece that you
really can't cut down the cost of
of replacing a leachate tank is 50 000
no matter how you look at it the cost of
replacing a monitoring well is three
thousand no matter how you look at it so
it is those capital expenses that we
always have to make sure that we have
enough to cover
those are the parts or pieces that sort
of contribute a significant amount to
that financial assurance pot so
this 820 that we're working on again a
10 contingency so without the
contingency you know we basically would
need
approximately
760 000 without the contingency
and then your other question was um
something and maybe i shouldn't uh
rephrase it had something to do possibly
this is
this mechanism is working as it's
supposed to work in that you can't
fulfill the obligations regardless of
the reason behind it and that this money
you know in the trust fund has been set
aside for this type of the situation and
that this is actually working
appropriately and des should be using
this money because regardless of the
situation you can't fulfill your
obligations
and again
i'd love to have all you guys in my
discussions with the des so um
again i think where where their hands
are tied is that the regulation
specifically states regardless that they
need a financial assurance for
30 years and if they are to make a
departure someone had said something
about precedent that may set one of the
biggest precedents is if you are making
a departure from the des rules
regardless of what happened prior to
and then someone else comes in and says
wait a minute you made us put an extra
amount or to cover an extra amount so
again sarah is a person to answer that
but i would say that that makes
that would work
um you know to that point i understand
what you're saying around thank you
around you know the 30 years and their
regulations but if you just locked your
doors and said we're done
then this money that's in the trust fund
is what des would have to use in order
to continue the work oh that's the
option and they know that that's a a
viable option and again if i didn't have
the passion to do what i'm doing here
you know i don't know who else on that
group would literally say i'm going to
leave my job for hours on end and talk
to everyone possible to get this thing
fixed again this is saving the state
taxpayers
well
maybe the same amount of money but we're
taking on the work and and and so this
is actually
a different
way
to get to the same result that may be a
better way if we're if we're thinking
about taxpayers money which i know
that's your job and i appreciate that
but you're absolutely right i mean and
again it's unfortunately not a threat
because none of us
are able to with day jobs run in ash
landfill and go out and try to figure
out somehow some way a mechanism
to create an income stream to maintain a
national landfill when we're an economic
development organization we want to go
out we want to improve newport and
sullivan county i mean that is our
mission our mission nowhere says you
know we will maintain an ash landfill
but you are absolutely right that that
is an argument that i've used
okay a few times sarah could you uh
rejoin us and uh
actually mr picken it might be helpful
if you could sit up here at this chair
of course if uh and that way and i
probably should have had uh
if that's okay with her i don't know
very congenial
but i think their hands are tied
okay uh somebody had
representative turcotte did you have
some questions for d.e.s
okay
okay so representative lin will bail you
out okay
miss kern i wonder if i could ask you
i understand what the you know what the
regulations say and i'm you know i
assume you've interpreted them correctly
and all of that but
isn't
doesn't
des
ex exercise in this situation just like
it doesn't in a whole bunch of other
you have to in other words
you don't the law doesn't say you will
take it over or i mean this isn't don't
you have sort of for lack of a better
term prosecutorial discretion to decide
well sure we could take over this
landfill because there's not enough of a
bond so to speak but
we're going to decide in the exercise of
our discretion
not to do so just like you know in a
criminal case there may somebody may
have committed a burglary but the county
attorney doesn't have to or the attorney
general doesn't have to prosecute they
can say we've decided for other reasons
we're not going to
des
does have
enforcement discretion
and what des needs to do is
weigh many factors
including the
liability that is presented for future
generations when a landfill does not
have proper financial assurance
i asked my staff you know 400 closed
landfills um if
if
many of them did not have enough
financial assurance and
they they all
their
became insolvent
what would that burden be and it's it's
hundreds of millions of dollars on the
state so so we need to keep that in mind
sure i understand but if i'm
understanding i'm sorry can i have it if
i'm understanding correctly there there
isn't as far as we know
there isn't another situation like this
and
it appears and you correct me if i'm
wrong it appears that
the the
operators of the of the this landfill in
question
there's no
again correct me if i'm wrong but
there's no claim that they operated in
bad faith or that they took you know
that somebody took some of the money and
went to aruba or anything like that as
far as we know they've done
they've done what they're supposed to
have done
i want to be clear that that econ has
been very good stewards of the
environment with this landfill right so
and i mean in those circum wouldn't that
be a pretty good reason to say you know
of all the landfills that and all the
operators of landfills in the state
that we might you know
we might want to go after
this is probably
not the one we want to do at for and
even though we don't have
as much of a
security as we'd like
they seem to be doing what they're
supposed to be doing
you know if if we take it over we're
gonna
we're gonna have to pay the money to
that's not there in case something does
go wrong
so far it hasn't gone wrong so why not
you know why not why not not try to fix
a problem that's not broken at least not
now
we we absolutely
absolutely don't want to take over this
landfill call financial assurance on the
landfill that's why we're working with
econ
um i think
your question may get at
the the problem
that
there needs to be money for annual
maintenance and monitoring as well as
the financial assurance
we can't we're our hands are tied as far
as the rules and regulations go we can't
authorize more disbursements from the
um from the trust fund
and that's how we find ourselves in this
situation
you
are you ready now
yes madam chair i am ready okay good
um
is the des prepared to take this over if
it needed to and at what point would you
um
if des needed to we
we have experience with another landfill
in the state calling financial assurance
on the landfill
that other landfill has
nearly spent down its financial
assurance account to zero so in coming
years we will be needing to figure out
how to fund additional maintenance and
monitoring at that landfill
but we have experience doing that sort
of thing
you do okay um
the 2014 rule change what was the
impetus behind that
well i was in a different part of des
moines you might be but i thought you
might know the answer
uh that rule change
included
this provision about financial assurance
clarifying it as well as some other
things
but my understanding is the reason the
30-year rolling requirement was
clarified
in 2014 is because staff had noticed
that there was confusion among the
regulated entities about it
was the confusion noted
uh in particularly on the econ situation
or was it something else that's not
something that i have heard
so i couldn't comment on that
thank you representative petry
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question uh
did you say collins
the the uh he was uh
uh yeah answering his question is that
is that the cause of aikman uh
landfill in farmington
no
there's a there's a trust there i know
and i was you know the what they had for
a reserve in that
for that landfill and i know it's
maintained by
an outside entity
because for the reason of taxation
because now the town of farmington can
recoup their
the taxes on a property because it's a
private entity
the the landfill i'm thinking of is in
the northern part of the state and
uh has has
no responsible party doing any work on
it
so well it has the state hiring a
contractor to do it so
follow up how does the cause enactment
in farmington how do they maintain their
uh
monitoring and whatever
i'm sorry i don't have information on
collins and aikman here with me today
because that that is a private
that is a private concern that went
bankrupt
and i'm pretty sure that des does not
you know they mon you know they they're
overseers but not
they don't take an active role in uh
that makes sense to me since it's not
one that's been brought to my attention
is one where we do take an active part
very good thank you
anyone else have questions yes
go ahead thank you i'm sorry um again
after following up on representative
lynn is the problem here the regulations
and not anything that econ is doing and
what i don't understand is is there a
regulation change that that
should be affected in order to allow you
to work with econ
i'm baffled as to the range of what des
can do and what they can't do it seems
to me that working with them should well
be within your your purview and your
your powers um so where are the where
are these rules that don't allow you
to work with them in this way and is
that is that basically the problem
we can uh we can work with them and
problem solve within the requirements of
the solid waste rules and the statute
149 m i don't have
specific citations for you here right
here at this moment
as far as a
rule change that's not something des is
pursuing if someone was to pursue a role
or statute change they would want to
evaluate the
impact on um the other 400 closed
landfills and how that would affect the
state and the taxpayers
represent turcotte
um
could you could somebody provide me the
list or us maybe with the list
of the 27 towns who were originally
involved
uh or point me to a website or something
or where i could just see what those
towns are absolutely thank you we could
do that
yeah uh
send that to janet if you would
okay thank you
thank you
so you know in follow-up to to i think i
i share some of the same kind of
concerns that representative murray
shares and that that is this
suppose that you say that you know the
rules don't allow you to to allow
the landfill operators to draw any
further money out to pay for ongoing
operating expenses from
but let's suppose if i am i understand
correctly that if the state decided
that it was going to take over this
landfill
you would you would succeed
to the trust
is that correct whatever the balance is
left in that you would
you would be
you would be entitled to take that over
and have that as an asset from which i
mean that's the whole purpose of having
that right
that is the purpose of the trust so
let's suppose that you did that
could you then use money in that trust
to
pay for operating expenses
to pay for the maintenance and
monitoring yes so
okay so i mean it's
this seems kind of circular if we
if you can do that
why couldn't you decide
you know just as a discretionary matter
to just say
well if we take this over we're going to
spend the trust money to for for ongoing
maintenance
the people that are operating it now are
doing a pretty good job of that why
don't we just let them do that even
though it does
reduce the trust
amount because we would be reducing the
trust amount anyway if we took it over
because it's it's two separate portions
of the rules um and we have a solvent
permittee in this case so the rules
don't allow it
um and we take very seriously not
exceeding the authority that's given to
us by statute and rule
so
if
i if we amended this bill to say
uh the 200 million dollars
no that
was whatever the figure was no no no no
how much is currently in your set aside
200 000
500 no no no no set aside oh yeah 200
000 right and that's earning interest
or something something it's earning
something okay
it's
yeah it's kind of probably like my money
market or something or other but okay
so we could amend the bill to say
that
uh
as far as this landfill is concerned
200 000
in this whatever it is meets the
requirement for
the
whatever
assurance fund
and just leave it at that
i mean and that way that covers
des
it covers
uh econ
and
we don't have to spend five hundred
thousand
dollars i mean i'm just
can i i'm just making you know i'm i'm
like hearing this
really really circular argument that's
going around
and i you know i'm i'm having some
problems representative heath please
instead of doing that would it be
possible to grant
des waiver authority
and be very specific
in relation to the terms of that waiver
and
that would allow them to go forward and
then
again in
quite frankly i think
we may have maybe 30 years from now the
legislators will be hearing the same
thing i don't know because i mean this
has the potential for some real problems
um but if des had that waiver authority
there might be other circumstances where
they need to do certain things like this
this seems like the rules are awfully
rigid
well we can't waiver the rules as you
know that's
that's
not our purview
uh
jalgar has approved the rules
and probably there is
nothing in legislation
that says other than
des will make rules
so
all that we can
i think all that we can do is say
you know this works
i mean
obviously
you know any rule that we have can be
waived
however as i'm listening to the
testimony
des is not at this point
willing to waive that rule
i mean that's how that's what i'm
hearing
and um and so
all that we can do in legislation is say
what they have
meets the requirements
and that they can spend money out of the
remaining
i mean that's that appears to be
to me anyhow
our our option
may i just make a comment on that
sure i think i mean i think your
analysis is exactly correct but i think
you know
i guess what
from my perspective what i would say is
if we reject this legislation
then des will be in a different position
and they will have to decide
whether they want to take over this
landfill
or
or not
i think
no they excuse me let's let's go ahead
mark
tell us what you wanted to say so just
getting back to the 200 000 so there's
other parts and pieces that make it very
difficult to just make certain
assumptions with that money and what it
can be used for so that was set aside as
part of the purchase and sale and
indemnification agreements that it only
has a specific purpose and i am told by
our attorney that we would be in trouble
by the uh charitable division if we
start taking money and use it for
unintended purposes and that might
prevent or present some personal
liabilities
so i don't know if we would be able to
amend the amendment the only way wait
i'm not looking for that money to go
anyplace other than to be targeted
as your
amount of money
if after
another 15 years
you
the landfill falls apart
i mean i'm not yep so that that that's
our our thought process with des is to
have them allow it but the only way i
think that would happen
is if they were to give us some sort of
waiver that if we were ever called on
the 27 towns to use the 200 that they
would release that from the financial
assurance mechanism because if it's part
of the financial assurance mechanism we
have to wait for them to allow us to
spend it and if it is restricted from
what its current use was
then we cannot put it there
so we still haven't had that negotiation
with des
but we cannot just arbitrarily put that
in and i'm not sure
if this group can to be honest um just
because it's got to be the des that says
yes we know you're using financial
assurance but here's the thing the only
time that 200 000 we've got to get out
of this thought process okay
the thought process is number one i'm
not going to give you 500 dollars
okay and i don't think there's anyone
else in this room that is willing to do
that
if there is speak up
but i haven't heard from the questions
that that is even a possibility
so
what i'm trying to do i think and what
we're all trying to do
is to somehow or other
help
the
landfill
continue to operate as they have been
and getting and
agreeing that
all they have to
the money that they have put aside the
two hundred thousand dollars covers
whatever assurances
that
des needs that's that's where i'm coming
from
representative
i'm sorry i i
like crazy one statement one question
you all are in a hell of a predicament
absolutely
um
the question for sarah if you could do
me a favor in addition to the 27 towns
could you confirm one way or another
that the rule change that was done in
this says 2013 but i guess it went into
effect 2014
that it in fact was not done
specifically for this
econ
issue
i will do my best however
our staff at all levels of des has
turned over since then
and
if there's not a note in a file there
will be no one to ask
i
i would ask that you do your ultimate
best to
see if you can figure that out thank you
do they
keep
do they keep um
detailed records of uh what goes on in
jail car like
you know i mean
yeah we have transcripts of those
meetings so we can go back and review
the uh the court reporting and and see
if there was any discussion relative to
representatives question whether it came
up a gel car anyways yeah
okay
so
does somebody
is that something you can easily find or
is that a heart no we actually our
office maintains those transcripts so
we've got those so i just need to find
the right meeting and look okay okay
so
just one follow-up clarification because
now i understand what you're saying and
i very much appreciate it so you're
saying that there's somehow some way if
we put an amendment that just asked
is it
is it an act of the legislator that will
say d-e-s you will accept this 200 000
as the obligation and they
need to follow again i i'm very green
okay i get it i was totally mis yes i
totally misunderstood but now i get it
okay
representative turcotte
just thought of another one
on this rule change
were there any other landfills trusts
that were affected
as econ has been affected by the rule
change
and if you don't know the answer if you
could find out
i want to be sure that i understand your
question
um
affected in financially in other words
when the rule change went into effect
were there others that were
short of money that they had to
then pony up
to get back to the 30-year rolling
versus fixed
got it thank you yes
representative did you have a question
thank you madam chair this is a this
sounds like this is a not withstanding
and then and then whatever you want to
put in there about the 200
because
it's a it's a special bill that's coming
in the second year and
we're not going to get it through anyway
even if we wanted to
thank you i i agree
represent murray
thank you apropo uh representative
turcotte um and the question of who else
would have been affected um there's a
uniqueness here in that if another
landfill might have been affected they
could rely on their tax base or they
could rely on their community the you
know the the community township or
whatever municipality for that taxes and
they don't have that option so i think
to be clear with his question um in
looking at who was affected the
circumstances of how they could acquire
money to uh meet the financial assurance
is important because the municipality
would not would be able to do this where
econ is clearly in a position where they
can't so does that
yes i i'm thinking it would be helpful
if
if there are other landfills that were
affected if there was a list and it
indicated whether it was a public or
private entity and had the name of the
permittee
that would be great
okay
are there any further questions
thank you madam chair
uh thanks again sarah for taking my
question um is this a
okay i understand it's a lined landfill
it's probably properly capped
what are the tests showing
coming from this
landfill i mean are they
you know are they pretty much uh petered
out as far as you know vocs and whatever
i'm thinking that mark may have that
information more closely at the front of
his mind
um
so again i'm probably speaking way out
of my subject matter but i do know that
over time the leachate itself has
reduced substantially and the only way
that that 200 000 can be used for
catastrophic that we were talking about
was if we had like 40 000 gallons a year
right now we're doing like 5 000 every
two years
so we are in we are trending with all of
the
metrics in a positive way the only parts
of pieces we don't know again not to be
specific but there's some new testing
with pfas
that we still do not know
and again i don't want to speak out of
turn but but the answer is it's trending
very positively
right and have you been approached by uh
these solar companies to uh
put a solar farm uh well i know i know
our town that's what they do
and uh a source of revenue which would
probably help in your situation and it's
quite a p uh 80 acres is pretty good
piece of land
so we did go down that path as one of
our alternatives and
unfortunately where it's located is
right between newport and claremont and
it does not have
three-phase power and the cost of
three-phase power was going to be a
million and a half
so the cost to get us power in order to
do it made it
not viable but that's a great solution
and that was one of our first thought
processes but we just can't get there
thank you
okay
i am
are there any other questions
okay
obviously
we still have a lot more thinking to do
on this
so
um
i will
schedule another
work session
sometime
um shortly
i think we have until
march
10th
but it'll be long before that
um
because des owes us some
things okay
and
we we need to try to figure out
um
you know
what we're going to do
am i wrong to suggest that there's
anyone here
that is willing to
provide five hundred thousand
okay so that's
that's where we're okay so
that's where we're at
so
i guess that the real thing is is that
we need to try to figure out if there's
a way
we can
make what make what they have
work
and it may not
it may not be
the best solution
but it is a better solution
than
econ
going
and i mean i i do know that the economic
council there
as mr lucas explained
is trying to bring
the town back newport back
to
you know to give them
a sense of
positivity
and i think that's occurring outside of
this issue
and um and so
you know we we we just need to try to
figure out a way to uh
to solve this so
i will um i'll schedule this
probably someday
we still don't know when we're going to
have session okay which is
which is kind of one of those
unless len knows i don't know that we
know
i'm not aware if it's actually been
publicly announced i do am aware but at
this point since it hasn't come from the
speaker's office
okay i know that we had talked about it
being the week of the
14th and
so
we'll see
uh i'll
i'll wait for that
but uh because it'll either be
the week of the 14th or the following
week
okay yes
just one final point um
i think you're correct about
the committee going down the road of the
500 000
my my major concern i think it's
representative lens has the same concern
is
if we can find a solution that it cannot
be on a
i hate setting precedence i hate doing
one-offs
for this situation because there'll
always be a next situation when we do it
so if we could just keep that in mind
yeah
can i just follow up on that sure and i
you know i'm bang my gather
i understand completely your desire to
to you know to find i mean this is it
seems to me this is a situation where
everybody's kind of operating in good
faith that you know it's trying to do
the right thing i completely understand
that and i understand the desire you
know
for a solution can i could i just
suggest though that
it may be that this is not something
that's appropriate for a legislative
solution in other words if we were to do
something like say
you know
create a carve out
for
this situation
and pass a special law dealing with this
situation
i would be really concerned about the
precedent we would be establishing as
opposed to
basically leaving
saying you know this wasn't i unders i
completely understand the parties acted
in very good faith trying to say well if
the legislature would appropriate this
money this would be a solution to our
problem but if the legislature says no
we're not going to
now the ball is back in your court you
collectively
and
my sense is that that's really where it
should be and
that
des will have to decide
is this important enough
that you know are we worried enough that
we want to take over this landfill and
stop what seems to be a pretty good
operation even though they don't have
all the assurances they should have or
are we willing to say okay
you know we're going to sort of wave our
rules because
if they decide to waive their rules
the the town certainly i mean the the
landfill operators aren't going to
object to that and i don't think anybody
else has standing to object so
they can do this
and
it's really sort of out of our hands and
kind of my sense is that's where it
should be is out of our hands
i don't disagree but
we heard what they said our rules are
fast hard and fast
that's that's what they said so maybe
they'll change their mind
okay
thank you all i'm gonna bang the gavel
thank you all very much thank you all
very much appreciate it
for coming today
you